dos años después del incendio que
amenazó con derribar la notre damme
sigue esperando su resurrección como el
colosal edificio que está en el corazón
de parís el enorme agujero del techo
sigue expuesto a cualquier fenómeno
pronto se instalará una cubierta
gigantesca contra la lluvia para
proteger la frágil mampostería mientras
que algunas obras maestras de notredame
como sus famosos rosetones se salvaron
de las llamas hoy el objetivo es
reforzar las bóvedas de notredame muy
dañadas y bajo el riesgo de colapsar
estamos proporcionando alivio a la
catedral dándole muletas apoyo porque
hay muchos puntos débiles hasta el
momento la consolidación de la
estructura de la catedral ha costado 165
millones de euros el siguiente paso es
la restauración propiamente dicha que
aún no ha comenzado y el plazo de cinco
años de manuel macro no está cada vez
más cerca las obras han sufrido
contratiempos debido a la contaminación
por plomo el mal tiempo y por supuesto
el coronavirus pero el general al mando
de la obra insiste en que todavía tienen
tiempo
es un calendario muy ambicioso pero
todavía estamos en camino de reabrir la
catedral a los fieles en 2024 2000 real
casco no estará completamente terminada
por supuesto todavía habrá que hacer
trabajos en el exterior sobre todo en el
muro exterior y otras obras que hay que
terminar y sobre todo hay que terminar
la consolidación del edificio que no se
hará hasta este verano alrededor de 200
artesanos técnicos e investigadores
están apresurando para devolver a
notredame su antiguo esplendor un
esfuerzo monumental respaldado por 833
millones de euros procedentes de
donaciones de todo el mundo